welcome to episode 82 of film courage my
name is Karin warden it's kind of cool
that we have ty West here in studio for
episode 82 as his last film the house of
the devil takes place in the early 80s
so it's a perfect harmony happening here
my name is David Brannon you can say
that today's episode is a prelude to
Halloween you know I don't think we
could have planned it any better in
addition to Ty West being here in studio
we also have filmmaker Tony Elwood as a
special surprise guest here in studio
Tony's in town from North Carolina
he made he's made his share of horror
films including cold storage which we're
gonna be screening tomorrow night and we
also have producer Paul Barrett who's
here with Tony and he's Tony's producing
partner he's in town from North Carolina
as well and unfortunately we couldn't
fit him in studio but he is hanging out
outside with our guy Ronan Rosner yes
let's wave to ya hello there Paul our
guest today is filmmaker Ty West ty is a
writer director and producer of horror
thriller genre films such as the wicked
the roost triggerman IFC's dead and
lonely the house of the devil cabin
fever - and his latest project the
innkeeper starring Sara Paxton Pat Healy
Kelly McGillis and Jorge riddle please
welcome to the film courage studio mr.
Ty West hello time hello thanks for
having me absolutely yeah yeah welcome
ty welcome Tony Tony thank you
absolutely so this is a creepy Halloween
show already love it
very cool well again gentlemen thank you
for being here I appreciate it well
let's get right into where you grew up
ty and what would you change about your
childhood if you could if there's
anything I grew up you know on the
filmmaking hub that is Wilmington
Delaware and you know I don't know I
mean I think changing part of my
childhood I don't know what I would do
different necessarily I'm an only child
which I think by default makes me a
little bit of a weirdo and I think I
just spend so much time just by myself
kind of I don't know figure things out
by myself and watching movies and
watching TV and I was
obsessed with I guess stuff I could do
by myself because I had no other choice
so if anything kind of informed me of
having my own opinions or having my own
sort of creative endeavors it would be
that you know it's not having anyone
else to do it with me so you know as far
as what to change there isn't really
anything I can think of like it may be a
bit cool to be like you know a
billionaires kid like that one I don't
have any like they don't have any real
regrets over my child but or anything
like that so you know it's worked out
okay so far okay very cool let's jump
ahead a little bit now I understand you
were featured in Teen People magazine
what's the story there
uh-huh well when I was in college I went
to the school I went when I was 18 I
moved in New York I went to the School
of Visual Arts and my friend there the
Sean Reed who ended up being in all my
short films and has been in the wicked
air and while he's in the wake of
Brisbane and the roost and triggerman
and more or less than some capacity in
every movie I've done we were standing
outside school and I he was probably
smoking a cigarette or something but
this girl came up to us and asked us if
we would be in this magazine and it had
something to do with it seemed like
icing to do with like fashion or like
kids in New York but then they put all
different clothes on us that doesn't
make any sense but um yeah it was this
weird afternoon that we have where they
took us down and like to this weird
stylish place and put us in goofy
clothes and made us kind of in the
extensions in her hair made us kind of
like I guess sort of model or whatever
but it was just a random thing that sort
of happened but it was fun but my mom
has the picture saved over so wasn't a
win a date with time it wasn't not a sad
way it was one and done you know we
understand that you have a photographic
memory you know what is this you know
what is this and how does it play out in
your life and and how has having a
photographic memory how does that
impacted your filmmaking well I mean I
would say I have a photographic memory I
don't know if that's really real I bet
someone who has a real photographic
memory is probably like would you know
spit on me for me saying that but for me
like I like I can't remember names to
save my life but I can member everyone's
face and as far as like movies and
things like that like I remember them
very well and I remember things that I
see and read and that's how like because
people used to say with houses and like
oh how did you get the 80s so accurate
and I have it didn't seem like it was
that accurate to me when I was making it
it just seemed like the best we could do
and then everyone came out saying oh
it's it's dead-on and it's so specific
but it really was just the way I
remembered things and I just tried to
recreate it to where I went this looks
like I remember it and I think that's
kind of how I make everything it's just
like I kind of have an idea in my head
of what things look like and I just try
to recreate that and if I recreate it
there's something that it looks weird I
just take it out so I don't know that's
I think it's generous to say
photographic memory I think it's because
I never people remember building names
so I just say that you're gonna make
keys but uh yeah works like to say hello
to Gregory Bain who writes in finally
sitting in the right place at the right
time per film courage hello Nellie Vail
75 that's Antonella Ally Stacey I hope
I'm saying that right
ll Carrington that's Lynette Carrington
and I guess coming back to Nelly Vale
I'm 75 and to know it was great to have
you join us for the live chat mom the
other night and it's great to have you
here on film curds today she's listening
in Germany Mojave 44 also checking us
out
hello Michelle you know when you type in
ty west on Google pages upon pages
images upon images come up we wrapper
but there's a lot of ty West though you
know we're really grateful to have you
here today how often do you do
interviews and and how important do you
believe it is for a filmmaker to have
relationships with the media I I
generally do them when people ask so
I've been fortunate that it's relatively
often I like doing interviews I suppose
I mean I like like for instance when I
screen a movie I hate doing an intro but
I like doing a Q&A because I sort of
like having an opinion so that that part
of it is sort of enjoyable to me as far
as the relation with the media I don't
know I mean I think there's like the
there's an egotistical side of it that's
kind of like since making film is so
traumatic it's kind of nice to feel cool
about yourself for a minute and have
people want an interview and I think
that's valuable and I think it's also
valuable for other
people out there specifically filmmakers
to hear from the people who are doing it
you know I know for me that like when I
first done some directors commentaries
on like laser discs and DVDs like that
was interesting because the first time I
never heard of anything like that and
you know is interesting you hear right
from the horse's mouth like what it was
like making this movie not everyone is
always thinking about it that way so not
everyone is really trying to educate as
much as they're just going with the
egotistical part of it and it's a fine
line because again I think making film
is so traumatic that anytime you get any
attention it's just like Huff thank you
please love me you know it's like it's
been so hard but yeah I mean I think
there are some people that do it I mean
like Quinn Tarantino does it very well
obviously he has like the gift of gab
but he's also he has a lot of good
anecdotes and a lot of good stories and
a lot of good sort of like us helpful
advice and you know that spits I think
it's cool and and I guess you know in
addition to that you know as I look
through a lot of the press you received
a lot of it you know does come obviously
from the horror genre you know that I
was telling Karen last night there's
just so many press outlets that are
horror related yeah do you feel like
that's a sort of an advantage you have
that that you know that you can gain
interviews and press from all those
multiple outlets that maybe that the
drama indie filmmaker doesn't have the
same opportunity it isn't it isn't it is
certainly better because you're more
press as better than no press I think
that horror press is generally the same
people reading it all the time though so
you're not really gaining much more of a
new audience as much as like the people
so as very was very beneficial my first
film the worst because when you're a
little budget movie and you have no one
should care about you when you can have
these outlets say like kind of vouch for
you no matter what the outlet is it
gives you some credibility and that
because we have no money to either make
the movie or promote the movie that's
very helpful so in the beginning it's
it's a kind of priceless now like I said
I feel to a certain degree that I'm just
talking to the same people over ever
again which is fine I like those people
but I don't know if it's as valuable
from if filmmakers like you know broad
and range as much as there is in the
very beginning but in the very beginning
I owe all those sites a lot of credit
because they they really saw some
pictures and read some stuff about the
Bruce and
got behind it and because of that it
made it seem like a real movie and that
was invaluable
so now you've released four films I
believe that fall into the horror
thriller genre and you're currently
working on your fifth yes all right okay
is there anything that you hate about
the horror thriller genre wait people
always ask what you like but I'm film
courage we like to take a spin on things
so what do you what irritates you a lot
actually I mean I think it's it's it's
sort of my favorite genre but it's
become like outrageously lowest common
denominator and mostly because I think
in the mid 2000s right around the time
that I was making with the rooster a
year or two before Hara became very
popular again and when it became very
popular can be very successful when it
became very successful everyone started
doing it and as soon as one thing became
successful it was like just do that
again because that works and so
everything became just aimed at like
well you know this particular technique
works very well so let's just run that
into the ground until it doesn't and
then try something else because you know
it's a business and that's the way
people look at and you can't really
fault them for doing that but you can
fault the audience's for being so stupid
as to just keep going to see them you
know so that's the downside I think to
the heart especially right now is that
you know if there's thirty horror movies
a year twenty eight of them are terrible
and the problem is that 28 of them still
make decent money so there's gonna be 28
more next year that are just as bad if
not worse because you sent the message
that you know even though they're bad
we'll go see it anyway
and that's really a shame and then when
there's those two really great ones they
don't always do as well and that's kind
of heartbreaking is when you when you
actually see a really great movie and it
doesn't succeed it's very frustrating
because if that movie succeed then you
see other great movies but when the
crappy movie succeeds you just get more
crappy movies and so I feel like horror
but more than any Java really is just
become the same movie over and over
again so a lot of copycats and no
originality yeah I mean everybody looks
exactly the same you know I'm just
curious Tony do you have anything you
want to add to what I agree I agree
wholeheartedly with everything you said
you know I mean we had the hardest time
getting
distribution for cold storage because
when we make hole so it took me 20 years
to get the film made and by the time we
got it made everyone was looking for you
know torture porn films and so you know
we set on it for two years until that
that that phase kind of went away and
then people started paying attention to
it again so you know when Hollywood or
distributors whatever's hot whatever's
got heat on it that's what they want
they want that and they want ten of them
hmm and you know they they just don't
want to take the risk on something
original they just do not so this is
really tough so what are some of the
best independent films you've seen this
year this year probably maybe my
favorite movie this year was the Joan
Rivers documentary because I'm a fan of
her so it was really satisfying I think
it's great movie um I thought winners
mom was very good
I think end of the void is pretty
amazing I really like Scott Pilgrim
which is speaking of a movie that no but
he says it's not independent film but
that's the movie that nobody's really
saw and it didn't do very well and it's
really kind of fantastic
I thought social network was very good
what else came out this is film courage
we have filmmaker 20 Elwood sitting in
studio with us and our guest today is
sitting right next to him and that's
filmmaker Ty West writer Seth Godin
talks about busy work that a lot of
people use to keep themselves appearing
as if they're working on something but
really accomplishing nothing and Seth
says that the real work is what someone
puts off it's a work that scares you
which you find kind of a million excuses
not to do tell us how you deal with this
if you fall prey to procrastination
maybe you don't how do you deal with you
know putting off certain things how have
you combated this in your career
avoiding certain things that you know
you're supposed to get to but you kind
of don't because they're uncomfortable
to do I think we all fall victim to this
I know I do
I also was struggling from an
uncomfortable standpoint procrastination
certainly you know on my own worst
anything everybody or any sort of like
artistic person in a way as their own
worst enemy
and I can be very self-hating so I think
the self-hatred is what motivates me but
you know there's also a really fantastic
book that Stephen King wrote called on
writing that I would recommend anyone
that writes because it's a lot of that
book is just it's about sort of his life
and how things worked out and how they
didn't work out but a lot of it's also
about just like you know most people sit
around waiting for the muse to come and
I think he is this kind of great quote
of saying it's to some degree like he
says again but you have to let it know
where you're gonna be and so he has a
very strict routine of like going every
day every day
writing for a certain amount of time no
matter how good or how bad it is doing
that going for a walk writing some more
and then that's it and that's like it's
like a day job for him and because he
gives himself that routine and because
he treats it that way he has no choice
but to kind of be creative and there's a
lot of validity to that because you know
I used to tell people like it's not that
hard to like write a movie but it's so
easy not to and I think that's like I
write my movies in three to five days at
the most because if I don't I will
either lose interest or I will start
thinking it stinks and I have a better
idea and that's what everyone who is a I
know I wrote like 30 or 40 pages and
then I kind of came up with something
better that's what everybody does but
like you just have to fight your way
through it and it's Terror is not
enjoyable like I don't find filmmaking
to be like a pleasant emotional
experience it's very traumatic and the
writing is just the same like it's
you've got to really force yourself to
get through the draft of it and then
once you get there and you realize like
oh like that wasn't that bad to do but
in the moment it's very terrible and I
think it's just a matter of not kind of
giving up and not like disguising giving
up as oh I have a better idea because
that's really all that is like you might
have a better idea but you can still
finish this one so does that mean you
have this idea sort of simmering it's
bubbling for a long time and then in
three to five days you just sort of yeah
I made it out so to say I mean because
that's a very short period of time are
you writing an entire first draft in
three and three to five days yeah if not
you know a first second third four I
mean the way I do it is not to say
that's a good way to do it but I do
think the the idea of like just doing it
is sort of very valuable but what I do
is I have an idea and then I
kind of a very rough like an outline of
just like kind of like or like a beach
heat as they call it in LA and like I
just kind of like figure it all out to
where I'm like alright I kind of know
what happens in the movie I don't know
specifics of the scene I don't know
dialogue but I know the gist of
everything and then I just locked myself
in and I just have a very miserable
weekend or very miserable week of just
not getting up from the computer and
it's horrible but like it'll get done it
usually takes me three days to write
about a 60 to 70 page first draft that's
really rough and then I print it out and
I go through it like like a teacher with
a red pen and like then it's really easy
because it's tangible it exists so even
though you feel really crappy about it
and it's kind of an overwhelming once
you're holding like 65 pages even though
the final drafts gonna be 90 pages 65
pages is heavy and you don't wow I just
did this in three days until you get
this kind of like extra boost of morale
and then you go through it and it's very
easy to take work that pre-exists and
make it better
what's very hard is when you're the
cursor is blinking on page 30 and
there's nothing after it that's really
hard to find the motivation once the
script actually exists then you just
read and go well this isn't very good
and you just fix it and I usually do
about three rounds of that so like my
first draft is really about 60 to 70
pages and then my second draft is about
75 to 85 pages and then so forth until I
get to the point where I can read it and
not feel like I have to change things
and then I'll usually let it be couple
people read it and then like a couple
weeks later I'll go back and fix a few
things that I kind of let myself slide
on but that's so far that's been my
process on all the six or seven scripts
that I've written or eight or nine maybe
it is so when you talk about being
critical of yourself
which I think any you know we talked
about creative people were very hard on
ourselves how do you combat that let
those voices maybe people from the past
or whatever it is telling you you know
good this you know this sucks whatever
how do you can bat that I guess you just
do it yeah I mean I know no I know I
think like if that's the situation that
if you certainly if you're struggling
for something of the past or with this
feeling that you can't do it well then
the only way to do it would be to do it
you know or like you just accept that
you're not gonna be able to do it and
you are you know a failure if that's
well that's the way like I look at
myself like if I can't write a script in
a week then I'm a big loser and I go
that's not true and I fight through it
now that's not healthy but that's just
how I do it
you know I'm this the only way nohow
okay and do you still have a day job no
you don't okay I did for my first two
and a half films I don't anymore okay
all right so when you came to that point
where you cross over from making your
own films to have having someone pay you
what was that like I mean was it scary
did you feel a huge sense of
responsibility on your shoulders were
you excited it wasn't it was great I
mean I'm not I'm not cut out for a day
job I'm not better than it I'm just not
good at it like I've had I've had like
I'm either I my qualifications are I can
write and direct a movie or I can be a
busboy
I have no intermediate skills whatsoever
I don't even how to work on movies like
when I did became fever - that is the
first time I've ever seen a Call Sheet
my life and as my third feature like I I
it I just it's one of the other so like
you know I've mowed lawns I washed
dishes I was a short-order cook
I sold shoes that was I when I made the
roost I was working at diesel selling
jeans and I would go to you know Spain
to the stiches Film Festival is one of
the biggest genre festivals in the world
and spend a weekend with Quentin
Tarantino and all these people and it
would just be like so much fun and then
I'd have to get on a plane to go home
and I'd have to go to work and it would
be like yesterday I was doing that and
now it's like 3232 let me go check in
the back you know and that that was very
much what I was accustomed to so when I
could stop doing that it was great I
mean that was a fine job but like I've
just not I'm not good at it now once you
don't have a job I guess unless you have
some giant hit which I've never really
had to where it's like I'm on easy
street there's definitely like this fear
of like well this the money that I'm
making for doing this is only gonna last
so long and it's not like you're gonna
clock in next week so you really have to
hustle to make sure that when that one
paycheck runs out there's another one
there or where the credit cards come out
again I mean I have a wallet full of
credit cards so you know it like I said
I'm not cut out for it so it's better
for me just to be able to just be a
filmmaker but it can be certainly when
the money is running low it's very
terrifying because the thought of going
back is just so brutal to me like if I
had to go back to washing dishes it
would just be like so tragic sure
now speaking of credit cards have you
put any of your own money into the films
probably all of them I've been fortunate
that with the roost which we made for
once the theatrical was done just a
little under a hundred thousand dollars
and III pliantly paid for ten thousand
that and Larry Fessenden was someone who
always put up his own money to make that
film he put up all's I wanted to make
triggerman and he fronted a little bit
of money for house the devil before the
finances came in so he's always been
really great and supportive about that
and not fearful and I'm very fortunate
to have met him and to have had that
luxury but you know on every movie
there's always something like it
happened my house the devil will happen
on this movie movie the innkeeper's is
like you know you'll finish the movie
and then something will be bothering you
about the sound mix or about the color
correct and it'll be little been done
for like a month new book I can't handle
how red that scene is or I can't handle
how loud that footstep is and I'll just
pay my own money to go back in there and
fix it so and it's never a lot of money
but it's you know a couple thousand
dollars that you'd rather not spend but
you know what are you gonna do I can't
live my whole life with a loud footstep
make a t-shirt you know eslint Porter
that's rider laying on Twitter she
writes in on writing by King is one is
the one writing book I never lend out
it's a great resource it's really
phenomenal it's a very easy read it's
it's it's really really great and then
it should be part of every writers
library how much should a filmmaker
spend on their first feature film
financially yeah you know yeah you know
whether you know Dassault what's a good
budget range for a first-time filmmaker
their first film feature I don't know
that it really matters I mean if you're
putting up your own money I would be
very cautious because generally like
especially nowadays the edge I mean
you're that's that money's probably not
going to come back to you so you know I
remember after the roost I was supposed
to make house the devil woman it fell
apart so we made trigger man we made
trigger man for $15,000 and and that was
we could have even probably done it for
a little less but we made it for that
cheap because it was like well certainly
there will be some profit to be made on
this level and you know it was there was
a stripped down as it possibly could be
so but not every movies like that I mean
if you
if if you has a mentality if you want to
make giant movies in life then I don't
think you can go make them over that
treatment because it wouldn't be
interesting to you and you would go do
it but I think you need to figure out
how how to communicate your giant vision
and so yeah I don't think it really
matters I think you know the less you
can spend probably the better off you
are but like if you're the kind of
person that only wants to make hundred
million dollar movies you're not going
to make a ten thousand dollar movie
unless you're one of those kids it's
like effects genius and you're just
putting all your own effects and
after-effects and I've never been that
person so I don't know well I mean
that's perfect because that was actually
our next question because we hear from
so many people that if you want to make
money as a filmmaker you've got to do a
low-budget horror film how do you
respond to that I mean have any of your
films lost money no I don't think so
I couldn't I've been fortunate that no
that hasn't happened to me okay and are
in a way is helpful because there's
always an audience like you said before
with all those internet resources I mean
there's just a community level that will
embrace it but you know that doesn't
mean that's not a sure bet you know and
it's like a mediocre horror movie isn't
gonna do you any good yeah so and
finding something to do that's original
and horror is very few and far between
so it's it's it seems like an easier
step forward than it probably is but
that haven't said the the the the movie
itself is the star and you don't need
famous people as much because you can
yeah but people get killed in it and
that's its own elements so that helps in
the low-budget it's always been good for
Loeb it's kind of it's like that kind of
like porn it's always had like kind of
its own hook sure and any thoughts you
want to add there's no she's gonna say
it's important you know you know I hear
that a lot too is if you make your first
film make sure so that the horror film
is guaranteed to make money that's not
necessarily true
and anyone shouldn't just go out and
make a horror film if it's not something
that you're passionate about you know me
I'm a passionate
horror film you know kind of guy I love
you know horror film and I know a lot
about it and and I think if you if
that's your passion that's the kind of
film you should make if your passion is
about you know documentary make
documentary but just don't go out and
make a horror film because you think you
can make your money back on this it's a
tough world that's what producers do
right you know we have this question
come in from Lynette Carrington she asks
what are some of the very creative ways
you have gone about raising money for
your film projects um well I've been
very fortunate that I've not been very
creative I met Larry Fessenden he liked
my short films and he said you know how
come you're not making a feature I guess
I don't have any money and he was like
well if I gave you a little bit of money
would you go to just go do it by
yourself and I just kind of lied to him
and said yes and then he actually just
manned up and gave me the money and I
made the movie and then after that when
the other movie fell apart I kind of put
it back on I'm like hey let's do that
again but we'll do it for less and he
went all right and so it's I've never
had to look very far for money just
because I met Larry Fessenden I'm very
fortunate because of that and I owe a
lot to Kelly Rijkaard who's who
introduced me to him and that made life
he's that you know he just said I'll
give you the money but you got to do it
yourself and then after that because of
those movies I got a job and then we
went back and made a house the devil and
because a house is dead well I got this
next job so you know I guess you're only
as good as your last thing I suppose so
I've just been fortunate you know and
it's been those have been fired a few
times also so like you know as far as
like big studio stuff like that happens
to so it's you know it can go either way
but you know speaking of sort of you
know we talked a little bit about
writing we've now talked about budget
you know are you thinking about your
film's budget in the writing process and
you know or are you simply thinking like
you know I'm just gonna write the best
absolute best story that I can or are
their budgets you know budgetary
considerations as you're writing well
also finding movie is kind of there are
finding money for movies as sort of a
con game in its own right and so I do
think about money because I think like
man I could I could talk this amount of
money out of someone so what could I
make with that amount like the Incubus
for instance we shot it at this location
it's this hotel that we lived in while
we were making houses devil so I knew
the place existed I
place abundant I knew that all people
that I've worked with know that place we
know the area cuz we just made a movie
there so it was like well this wouldn't
be so hard to make a movie there and
it's an interesting place so that I knew
would be an inexpensive kind of setup
for a movie and I knew how much the
people that pay for houses ever were you
know interested or willing to spend on a
movie so there was no sense in writing
like a thirty million dollar movie in
heaven we don't do this so it was you
know I knew what I could get all of my
own friends and crew members to get back
out there making movie I knew what it
would take and so that was a big part of
writing this movie it was like I wanted
to get back out there and do that and I
want to do something very different than
house The Devil's so that part of it yes
that even said you know when houses
devil that house was supposed to burn
down at the end it was in the script but
we couldn't afford to do that so and not
only could we not afford to do that I
didn't have the confidence that like the
CGI that we could afford would be any
better so you know cuz the option was
wolf we can't burn the house down well
we'll just do it as an effect but then I
was like but I don't think we have like
I don't have the confidence and the
people that would do that effect because
it's not like it's like wet is gonna do
it so it's like it'll turn into the
sci-fi channel movie so we just opted to
just not burn the house down which is
fine it's not as good necessarily not as
big but that's part of the low-budget
world that you just kind of like you
just have to deal with that and same
with any fevers there's a bunch of
things that's like but it couldn't quite
do it but we'll do something you know
it's not worse it's just different do
you make your films for yourself or do
you make them for an audience I make
them for myself I've been I'm aware of
I'm a pretty personal filmmaker in that
like I write direct edit and sort of in
a way produce all my movies which is
it's just cuz it's the only way to know
how and it's you know it's it's less of
a career or more of a lifestyle for me
so in that regard it's what I'm trying
to accomplish for myself that having
been said I'm aware of like you know
scenes that are gonna be effective for
an audience you know I'm aware of I can
have some of what will be suspenseful
what will be scary what will startle
people and what wicked will laugh and of
course if none of those things went that
way that would be depressing like if I
were in the theater no one was scared
and no one was loud it was doing oh my
god was swinging to miss but I feel like
I have a pretty
like I have decent taste and I have a
pretty hard on myself so if I think it
works if it can work for me it's gonna
work for some other people another one's
gonna like it but like it should work
for what I'm trying to accomplish in one
of the interviews we read about you you
mentioned discovering the people that
you can work with and the ones that you
can't tell us what kind of people you
cannot work with you want the good stuff
I mean as a director you're dealing with
everybody film is a collaborative
process so who can you not work with to
name names but sure types of people all
right well I'm kind of a handful you
know like I'm pretty from doing all
those jobs and having made movies myself
and done every job one time despite not
understanding of real movie jobs like
I've done everything that's squirt of
blood on people while holding a camera
of you know made schedules myself done
everything myself so I I know how all
the jobs work so when people tell me
they can't do things that bums me out
because it's like no we can do it and I
know how and now I feel like I'm doing
your job and I get very frustrated that
because I come in like and I go all in
making moving I'm very serious about it
so I don't like people especially in
low-budget well a lot of people are
they're just a party and that's a bummer
you know because it's like yeah the job
sucks yeah the hours suck and yeah
you're in some crappy part of the
country and the only good thing
apparently is the beer but like you know
this is two years in my life
I know it's just three weeks for you you
know hoping you know but it for me it's
it's two years of my life minimum and
like your permanent record so I get very
serious about things so I like people
who are as serious and I like people who
can really who are better than me which
is not to say that I'm great it's just
that look like for instance Jade Healey
production I work with is like fantastic
and it's like better than me and
elevates me and makes me work harder and
Graham Resnick the sound designer and
Jeff price the composer which is who I'm
working with right now on the
innkeeper's they're better than me and
you know because of that it kind of
forces me to like come up to their level
and challenge them to do better than
they normally do and that kind of
relationship I think is exciting and
that makes interesting and I you know
quotes better product people who are
just kind of like half-assing it or just
middle the road that I have a hard time
with because I take things very
seriously and I just want people to do
the same so you like perfectionist maybe
yeah I mean yeah I do I mean I like
people who are really gonna work really
hard I like people that are gonna make
me think I'm not working hard enough
because that's impressive and that
that's exciting to me interesting that
you know we have this comment from movie
angel
that's from Martella your guest today
has a lot of humor a pleasure to listen
he's actually very funny okay that's
part of the self-hatred is when I moved
to New York I wanted to do stand-up
that's what I wanted to do but I don't
have the guts to do it or I don't have
the confidence to do it so I made movies
instead mmm but that is just an up is a
very self-hating thing I think you find
humor and so it's kind of transcended
into this and and who have another
question from Lynette Carrington do you
think some big-budget films could have
been done on a small budget and been
just as good and do you have any
examples I don't they give me the
example yeah
yes I'm sure the answer is yes but I
don't I don't have an example of where I
feel like someone spent whoa they spent
too much money yeah a lot of times I
think there's movies that don't look
like big-budget movies but have a lot of
famous people in it and you spend a lot
of money just having them in it and I
think that is maybe where it could have
been less but I don't mean you try
telling yeah yeah and Lynette what I
just saw is there was an article
published this week that has to do with
sort of the new 40 million-dollar drama
that a lot of films that were being made
for 80 million dollars 100 million
dollars are now being cut back and 40
million dollars is a level that's
working currently the social network is
a 40 million dollar drama and I'm having
trouble recollecting the other one that
was just made that was successful at the
40 minutes so that there's um some
examples of them cut okay also I don't
know this for effect but I'm like I
guess Paranormal Activity 2 just came
out and is doing very well
mm-hmm I bet they made that for a lot
more in the first one I bet if they made
it for the state I bet if they made it
for the same amount they'd be making
more money right now I'm sure they're
doing hand-over-fist but at the same
time like I bet this new ones they've
costing I don't know what the personal
costs some thousands of dollars 15 grand
15 that seems fake but that might you
know it might have been 30 grand I don't
think
but like um you know I bet this one was
a couple million dollars and that really
kind of defeats the business model but
you know it not if it's making
everything a twenty million dollars and
Friday so yeah they know what they're
doing but that's an example of a movie
that's like the whole conceit of the
movie is this is low-budget and then you
make it for millions of dollars it's
like well that's weird like you know you
build a house instead of just finding a
house but I would do that you know if I
was gonna make a sequel to a low-budget
movie and I was like well pay my
mortgage you know like that's where I
want the money to go so I get it
so tie your first film the roost
premiered at South by Southwest did you
have a connection to get into the
festival how did that happen and that's
that's a tough that's one no that's just
a credit to Matt Denver who at the time
was running the festival I sent a copy
and he called me out of the blue I
didn't know who he was and he said hey
man I'm calling from South by and I was
like oh cool and I figured if he's
calling this got be good news and then
he was like yeah your DVD doesn't work
and so I panicked and I sent him like
you know 45 more DVDs and he called me
like a day or two later and was like
look I guess the DVD worked for the
first scene and then it stopped working
so I sent him more copies and he calling
back but there - later I was like
alright so watch the rest and let's do
it and that's really just kind of how it
went down I was like great and then we
went there so I mean that's an example
of like when you fill out that
submission forms I mean now I'm on
another end of things where like I have
relationships with certain programmers
where it doesn't get you to the front of
the line but it's like I know like you
know Matt doesn't worth any more but
after being in sound byte for several
years you know it was very matt was
always very aware of me and I was always
very aware of him so when the time came
around for the festival we'd be talking
about the movies and that it's nice
because there's a personal issue doesn't
mean it's gonna get in but it's that's a
little easier but when you know nobody
and you just blindly submit they watch
it I mean he called me outta nowhere had
no idea who I was and that was that so
you know I submitted trigger man the
same way except for again we knew each
other by then so it you know it's it's a
little bit again you you feel like
you're gonna get rejected just the same
but you do know them so when you do get
in you feel when we're talking about
going there and was that you submitting
or did you have someone submit for you
an agency a manager that was just you I
just did a filling out the forms filled
out the floor and put the check in the
mail and sent it off so that's the one
benefit is after you made of people we
sometimes they waive the check process I
was just gonna ask $40 do you ever ask
in the beginning did you ever ask them
to waive the fees I know some people
swear by that no I didn't I didn't think
you'd be allowed to ask I thought they'd
hate you if you asked that I literally I
just I went on the website saw how to do
it I mailed it and cross my fingers and
thank Matt downer like the movie because
without that there's no way I would be
without Larry Fessenden without Matt
family those are two major moments for
my first film that if those two things
happen I had priced I'll be working at
diesel you know we have a couple
comments here Nathan Cole writes in
that's water whole movie Paranormal
Activity 2 was made for the 3 million so
there's there's the budget there and rad
effects agrees if you're working on a
film it's it's important to be a
professional think like a pro do like a
pro aka perfectionist so he you know I
guess he likes your commentary there so
you know it's great to see some some
good feedback coming in we're talking
film festivals have you have you since
since that premiere South by Southwest
have you played a lot of film festivals
and do you think you ever stopped
playing the festival circuit with your
films I've played in tons yeah I really
like film festivals I think yeah if you
do a big studio movie then maybe there's
really no value for it because you're
gonna get it you know you're gonna get
released in all those cities or states
regardless but it's you know it's nice
like I said like it's it's traumatic to
making a movie and to go around and have
other people who have kind of been
through that trauma like kind of you
know I've met a lot of really good
friends I mean I think in 2005 South by
Southwest had a very good year and
that's where I met a lot of people that
I'm still very close to today like it
was my first film was there Joe Swanberg
first film was there mark and Jay
Duplass his first film was there and it
did a whole series of people like that
and I just I got to know all those guys
and we became very good friends and we
became like friends and collaborators
and very kind of helpful to each other
over the years and that's you know when
you live in Wilmington Delaware like
there is no one else making movies so
when you go to South by and you meet
some other kid who made a movie for
$10,000 and you're both there was your
first films not know what you're doing
and you're getting kind of some respect
and some credibility like it's very
satisfying you know and I've since kind
of worked
Joe is held on all my movies and I've
helped him on the holidays and it's it's
that that stuff is invaluable you did
something very interesting with the
release I'm gonna go move here to house
of the devil it was released on VOD
first and then it went into sort of a
limited theatrical release can you tell
us more about this this released
strategy and how it ended up working out
for you guys yeah I mean that release
strategy is Magnolias thing that's what
they do
you know they release especially around
Halloween they really release a horror
movie I think on October first and then
they released it theatrically right
around Halloween and it sounds like it
shouldn't work but it does you know it
worked very well
I think the movie to the best of my
knowledge is the most successful on VOD
as opposed to all the other excuse me
platforms that it has and it's one of
those things that I just trusted that
magnoliid knew what they were doing
because I had such a good time with them
as a distributor that I was like oh this
must be working and it did you know I
guess for me maybe a week before instead
of a month before it sounds a little
better but I think the reality is that
the cities that it's releasing
theatrically
don't have as much competetive in New
York or LA and the movies in the
Angelika or the new art of the sunset 5
you're more likely to go see or the
ArcLight you're more likely to go see I
guess it won't be Arclight because it's
if it's VOD I don't think our flight
will show it but you're more likely to
go theater and see the movie and not VOD
it but if you live in Kansas the movies
not coming there you know so it's either
like spend 10 bucks and watch it and see
it a little early to give yourself like
that's a nice thing that they do for
those people is like not only is it
never gonna come to you and that's a
bummer instead of waiting for DVD we'll
even give it to you before the theater
and it's good for word-of-mouth it gets
people talking about it so I mean I
think it's great I think it's also just
it's an inevitable future I mean I think
the inevitable feature is probably what
Netflix Instant has done because that to
me is the most groundbreaking thing I've
seen but this is just where it's headed
is you know I was at Best Buy the other
day buying something and 65 inch TVs are
1,200 bucks now so it's just like people
are gonna have big TVs and sound systems
it's just the way it goes in all your
films are on Netflix yeah I mean I think
how's the Devils on instant it's on I
don't know if the other ones are but
they should all be there you know one
thing I've been trying to figure out
here you know I know when Netflix went
when they when you sort of go with them
at least for their DVD distribution deal
with they sort of do an overall buy out
where they're gonna buy a certain amount
of DVDs do you not what do you know how
the deal is set up for the licensing in
terms of the net did you know the
streaming you know what I don't what the
differences I don't think that's really
the future I've had this conversation
with a bunch of people I think Joe
Swanberg and I had it recently was that
like Netflix incident has really been
the
biggest like whoa you don't pay to watch
it you pay a month and you can watch
whatever you want and you can watch it
instantly and I judge the contest for
IFC and by judging that they gave me a
PlayStation 3 which hooked up to Netflix
right through my TV and it looked so
good because I didn't want to watch it
on the computer and no it's worse than
that but when I can watch it on my like
50-inch TV it was like a whole different
animal and I really woke up to how kind
of progressive that that is I don't even
know how they do it so well but I don't
also don't know how they can be making
revenue because if you can watch the
same movies 67 times and you're only
paying ten bucks a month how does that
work they must have a way that it works
or they must be scheming a way that it's
going to work in the future I might gut
just over the years of growing up thinks
that the service will change and will be
less good so it can make more money but
as of right now hopefully not because
Netflix has always been good about that
you know and it's a big testament to
them that when they started up it was
nursing when I was in New York when it
first started up in the early 2000s and
all those like blockbusters everyone
kind of scoffed and I'm like this isn't
gonna work
and like man like they just shut it down
so that's it's it's pretty cool so it's
if they stick to being a cool company
and and trying to be progressive I think
I think that's the future I just want to
see them helping out us content creators
and you know putting this figured out
because I have to like if people stop
getting DVDs in the mail which I mean I
reduced my plan drastically to getting
one DVD in the mail because someone's is
on input in the beginning there wasn't
that many movies available and now
there's like they add 15 or 20 a week so
it's it's gotten to be so many and so
people will stop getting the ones in the
mail eventually and once they stop doing
that
it wouldn't if they're not making money
they're gonna figure out a way to do it
you know so it would be great if you
could make a movie for ten thousand
dollars like the Paranormal Activity and
you could sell it directly to Netflix
and have a profit thing but every time
someone watches it on instant you get
money especially for documentary
filmmakers because I think a lot of
people watch documentaries on Netflix
like that's a direct line to the
audience and you cut out all of the
middlemen and all of the studios and all
of the you know paying the ask people
that would be really like a massive
independent film movement you know it's
gotten easier and it's gotten cheaper to
make movies over the years we're seeing
sort of this this glut of film
being produced every year so it you know
that that part gets easier not now it's
getting that much more difficult to make
people aware of your foam to draw
attention to it how do you go about
drawing attention to your work I don't
know if it's if it's more difficult to
draw attention because well I guess in a
way that like you're now one of a much
larger number um so maybe that's
something where like a horror movie it
gets more notification or a
controversial movie or I mean maybe that
helps highlight it but I don't know
that's just kind of a you know the
whoever hustles the most or with a
squeaky wheel I guess it's the only
really thing you can do about that I
think the good thing is that movies have
become so much cheaper and they become
so much more accessible for people to
make for me they like like growing up
making movies is not something I don't
ever talked about what I wanted to do it
it was like no no no no people don't do
that someone else does that somewhere
and especially in high school like I
didn't have TV production classes or
filmmaking classes where you learn how
to do any of that stuff or edit and I
never knew about any of that stuff I had
a film history class where I kind of you
watched all the sort of classic movies
and kind of learn why they were great
and that was very helpful to me but I
didn't didn't know about editing or any
of that stuff like I learned all that on
my own nowadays I bet kids in fifth
grade there's probably classes in school
with iMovie and they're teaching or
final kind of teaching you how to make
movies because now just like when I grew
up skateboarding which is what I did was
like that was frowned upon like it was
borderline criminal and now if you start
skating when you're like six you might
be a millionaire by the time you're 18
and people encourage you to do that and
so it's really changed a lot into things
that were underground things that were
like kind of gritty or art are now
commercial avenues and so because of
that so many more people do it and that
means there's almost more bad stuff to
sift through so you know it used to be
making a movie was very difficult and
now it's just making a good movie is
difficult and you mentioned earlier that
you met a lot of people I think at
festivals around like 2004-2005 and
you've probably seen a lot of talented
people come and go why would you say
some of those people have stopped making
films
I guess money you know it's like I
worked at the the mall and I met a lot
of people who also worked at the mall
and a lot of people still work at the
mall and it's not because they had
different opportunities or I had
different opportunities it's just you
know I think it's important that like
like it sucked when I sold jeans and
made a movie but I just kept doing it
you know and it was not pleasant but but
I just keep doing it and keep making
movies I mean I went like house the
roost when it by the time we did the
theatrical ourselves it was about a
hundred thousand dollars is what we put
into that movie we shot it for 50 when I
when the house devil fell apart and I
pitched triggerman hilarya I my whole
thing was like okay you gave me
ultimately hundred thousand dollars to
make the last movie give me ten thousand
dollars to make this movie surely he'll
say yes to that because we had a good
experience and the ruse made money so
surely he's not gonna go well this is a
bad idea
but that's most people don't want to
take a step backwards most people make
their first film they make their little
movie they made it for cheap and they
got attention for it and now they expect
to go do a big movie it didn't happen
for me and it didn't happen for a lot of
people and some people kept making
movies and some people didn't I won very
inspirational moment for me was 2005 the
roost was there met all those people in
2006 I went back just to hang out and
Joe Swanberg was there with another
movie and I was like when did you make
this other movies like right after I
made the first one and it motivated me
so much because I was like I was
thinking I'm gonna get to do some other
stuff and he just went right back to
making a movie and because that he's
here again
getting doing this living this
experience all over again and I went
home that day and that's what I like
wrote trigger man that's what I call
there and said we got to make another
movie because you know the competition
the friendly competition but just seeing
Joe nonchalantly be like what do you
mean when did I make it I made it right
after the other one I was like oh you
know it's like he beat me you know and
so that really motivated me to get out I
keep doing and after that experience was
very eye-opening that as soon as I
finish trigger man it was like where's
the next thing where's the next thing
and I just became very motivated to
always be doing stuff and not rest on
your laurels and so it sounds like
stayin hungry and staying humble because
I noticed a lot of times people they get
a little bit of a big head oh well
that's not good enough I don't want to
do that so it sounds like you were
willing to do whatever it took yeah I
mean I think you get humbled you know
what I mean it's like I'm I can be a
sort of
arrogant is that you have to have a
right level of arrogance to be a
filmmaker because you have to believe
you know more and everybody and you have
to have the comments think you could do
something that's kind of crazy
so you have to have a certain amount of
arrogance to you but you know if you
think that you're just gonna rest and
things are gonna where you will be
humbled by the experience and that's
that's what happened ice Joe was there
with a new movie and it humbled me to
where I went man
I dropped the ball he kept going and now
I'm behind and that's just my own mental
thing and Joe's a good friend of mine so
that's why connected with me so much but
like ever since then I've always been
like just I'll keep going because it's
your fault if you don't we're coming up
on the end of the show here but let's
just wrap up with what does a filmmaker
need to know for 2011 and beyond to
advance their career that's I don't know
it seems to be different for everybody I
think 2011 like we talked about with
Netflix there's so many more
opportunities they're not as financially
viable back in 2005 people actually
bought movies for a decent amount of
money and you that's what happened that
doesn't really happen anymore so you
know I think just to figure out the
movie you want to make and you know if
you can make it for cheap you're
probably ahead of the game all right
okay well time has gone by very quickly
here thank you gentlemen
see ya thank you Mike and time Tony did
you have a good time yeah I sure did I
hope everybody comes out to you yes oh
that's a good theater to the downtown
exciting all right we've been speaking
with writer director producer Ty West
for more on ty please visit house of the
devil movie calm and keep up with him on
IMDB you can also see ty @ the filmmaker
forum this coming weekend at the DGA in
Hollywood and also thank you Tony thank
you thank you gentlemen and thank you to
all of you for joining us on yet another
edition of film courage here on la talk
radio calm also thank you to Rowan and
Rosner our tech engineer he keeps us
sounding great and he's built film
courage calm which we are so excited
about and we look forward to next week's
film courage where we will speak with
Scottish filmmaker David Paul Baker
until next Sunday have a great week
you